Kim Kardashian breaks her silence on
Kylie's pregnancy Plus Sasha Pieterse ax
on her pretty little spin-off well folks
Kim Kardashian is not here for your fake
news especially when it has to do with
her and her sister Kylie the
kardashian-jenner family has been fairly
quiet since news broke that Kylie is
expecting her first child with Travis
Scott but on Tuesday
Kim slammed the one report that said she
was not so thrilled about the baby news
a source close to Kim tells people she
didn't respond well at first and claims
it took a while for her to process it
after all that she and Kanye have been
through to get pregnant you'll remember
that Kim ei is expecting their third
child via surrogate and Kylie's
expecting a baby around the same time
Kim took to Twitter and straight-up said
this sounds like a very fake story she
added and speaking of fake stories the
media is super Shady for posting fake
quotes from Caitlyn when she hasn't
spoke to anyone now I know there are
like half of you out there who've been
asking why do we care in fact my
favorite comment from yesterday's
episode was my neighbor's dog is also
pregnant it should be on the news
alright that was funny you got me that I
was good but look are we oversaturated
with Kardashian news yes are there more
important things going on in the world
absolutely but this is a fun
entertainment show and you guys this is
great juicy Kylie is only twenty years
old she's so young her cosmetics line is
on track to becoming a billion dollar
company plus she has not been with
Travis Scott for that long it took us by
surprise and judging by the family's
silence I think they were pretty shocked
too and we're just now peeling back the
layers you guys it's only in the
beginning so stay tuned for more but I
do gotta move on to last night
Dancing with the Stars shark tanks
Barbara Corcoran was the first to get
axe and there's a second elimination
tonight I'm looking at you Nick Lachey
who sadly got the second lowest score of
the night his wife Vanessa however dance
through literal blood sweat and tears of
her injured toe last night and with 24
points she tied for first place
alongside Victoria Arlen and Jordin
Fisher now I told you guys last week
Jordan is one to look out for he's got
the theater background and clearly it's
working in his favor because besides the
moves he was serving some face but the
honor of Most Improved goes to Pretty
Little Liars start sasha Peterson she
shook off the nerves and told ET that
she's feeling much happier and confident
on the show and she's got plenty to
celebrate too because it was just
announced that she's getting a pretty
little spinoff
that's right Sasha and her PLL co-star
Janel Parrish will start in a new pilot
for freeform called Pretty Little Liars
the perfectionist cameraman thison found
out backstage what we can expect which
is amazing I'm so glad to announce it
actually I realized that I can announce
it today which I was kind of blindsided
about which was right which I'm so
excited about gotta be something new I
love that I guess flawless and so I mean
you know it's a character that's dear to
my heart for seven years and it's a fun
new world and Marlene our producer is
incredible she's just a genius and so I
can't wait to be on this journey with
her got to get him on the show I would
love that yeah alright we're gonna stay
on the reality TV train because season
13 of The Voice kicked off on Monday the
first with miss Jennifer Hudson as a
coach now there was some incredible
performances last night but the most
epic 26 year old store clerk
Lucas Holiday homeboy wild customers at
the Dollar General back in Michigan but
he literally stunned the coaches with
his rendition of maxwell's this woman's
work
[Music]
make it
[Music]
we're with you Jennifer we were shocked
too Jenny had turned around for the
Michigan native and as you can tell she
and the rest of the coaches were very
floored by his appearance as Blake put
it you couldn't believe he couldn't
believe Frasier was staying up on stage
I couldn't even get to that line all
right you didn't think Jennifer Hudson
wasn't gonna grab the mic and saying the
didja watch the sledge as the American
Idol alum jumped on stage for a gospel
duet with her new team member
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mm guys I am such a sucker for shows
like The Voice and it's not just because
of the SAP stories but moments like that
I'm here for team J Hut and clearly it's
gonna be a good season you know what
let's keep this good music going
do you guys catch chance the rapper on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert last
night chants performed a new song about
the American dream and it's a song you
told Colbert he came up with in a matter
of days he wanted to do something fresh
but in true chance the rapper fashion
it was also impactful take a look like
thank God clean water and Donnell got
teen daughters and black friends and
Gabe cousins y'all just don't say
nothing noted that they come in these
bowed tongues confess it the last ones
get in first if some questions not ease
the first world problems that make up
keep on playing we gonna shake this up
keep on telling us we making it up the
American dream may you never wake up
another one another one I got chills
watching that and I just had to give
chance a little love today and you know
what we're gonna give it right back to
you thank you guys so much for watching
say if you like what you see them be
sure to subscribe to et's youtube
channel keep watching keep liking and i
like you right back
praise oh so good